ça fait non ma femme est morte il ya des
conneries et oui je suis veuf attends
attends c'est la troisième fois que tu
es veuf dit oui la première elle est
morte
mais de quoi elle a mangé des
champignons vénéneux [ __ ] pas de cul
mais de quoi elle est morte la deuxième
incroyable elle a mangé des champignons
vénéneux deux fois çi c'est incroyable
là ils ces dernières de quoi elle est
morte elle s'est fracturée le coup c'est
quoi un accident de bagnols fait non
elle n'a pas voulu manger les
champignons j'ai cyril avec cette
dernière conquête pardon assurer seul
avec une illégitime on va dire d'un coup
il ya un ogre qui déboule 2052 ou là des
bras comme les cuisses de cyril quoi il
est rappelé à financer des cyril d'une
main c'est le tour de la taille comme ça
ils l'attrapent avec l'ongle de son pied
droit et c'est un rond parterre
d'environ deux mètres de diamètre toi
france irait là mais claude mas le posse
dans l'euro et dit toi tu sors de ce
rond et je te dise le ciri l'ecofin et
la traversée de ciani la baisse mais la
belle c'est bon et au bout d'une heure
et demie hissbach donc ça vient serrer
un peu décoincé 1 chez cache pas voici
ray écroulé de rire
dans le cercle que log il est tracé et à
lui dit dimanche elle
j'aime me faire défaut c'est boonen et
toi tu rigoles et la série lui dit alors
ah non je suis sorti trois fois du sert
qui me promet d'y arriver
ces deux histoires de tout à l'heure
c'est celle même naquit qui est un peu
fatigué j'adore j'adore ce gars là y
débattent déjà j'avais gars qui s'en
occupent qui vient et qui fait tu
t'ennuies oui moi je ne sais pas si
c'est pour voir ce qu'on va faire un jeu
on va faire des devinettes
d'accord je vais te donner des
devinettes et pour pimenter le jeu
si tu trouves je te donne 2 euros
d'accord c'est plus la jemaye qui pense
j'ai fait alors écoute bien c'est très
facile
c'est un animal d'accord avec des
oreilles comme ça il n'aime pas les
chats et il fait où sont pas taxés au
nom non scellées pas taille crayon d'un
mois 2 euros c'est complètement ridicule
concentre toi je te donne une autre
devinettes attention c'est encore un
animal sacré moustache ça n'aime pas les
souris et ça fait mien si vous êtes une
arme en revanche elle n'est pas du tout
une armoire en chêne et le tournoi deux
fausses et ridicules
on va faire la suite d'accord maintenant
c'est toi qui me posent une devinette
et pour pimenter le truc si je ne trouve
pas je te donne 20 euros d'accord avec
toi dit c'est mon sac le même
et le mec qui fait de quoi c'est pas dit
que c'est un animal 17 potes
ces mots à la russa gless seguin et
disent que tu suis vraiment désolé voilà
20 euros c'était quoi
je ne sais pas chef de zone euro
[Applaudissements]
voilà
c'est génial il fait toujours le même
personnage et puisse toucher bils
touchera jamais tu dois noter que la
semmaris son mari sinon j'ai saint cloud
azure bien mec et des bouteilles de
plongée toyer d'équipé pour orange et le
gie mètres en dessous du niveau de 2 you
ils regardent les poissons et d'agde où
il ya un mec qui arrive à sa hauteur
il est un petit peu hagard et où la
juste son petit maillot de bain il n'y a
absolument aucun équipement et ont crevé
qu'il était dit qu'est ce que fait chier
dis moi je suis en vacances je regardais
les poissons edit je descende à 20 mais
on va voir des 120 m cinq minutes plus
tard mais qui arrive à sa hauteur des
grands gestes que ça les yeux tout ronds
et dit que tu fais chier suis là je vais
les seuls à 30 mètres va bien voir et sa
trente mètres trois minutes plus tard il
a alors bien le plongeur exaspéré il
prend son ardoise et le crayon qui écrit
sous l'eau et les crimes mafieux police
que faites-vous à cette profondeur sans
matériel et le mec lui arrache ardoises
des mains pour le silo il est il écrit
je me noie connard
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est jean-marie iran et rentre
chez lui il dit chérie je suis passé à
la boulangerie lâcheté des chouquettes
et s'appelle m'a dit tu es mon fils tu
attends tu es pas de chicane d'abord ce
à travers d'un petit village et il ya un
petit mec c'est un pis techniciens comme
ça il est touché cif et il s'est rendu
compte que oti de sa femme sa femme le
trompait avec le boucher mais le boucher
c'est c'est un mot on sera ce n'est
qu'une une musculature et je suis le
petit technicien fois il sait que sa
femme le trompait est salée l'air mais
sa femme est en train de lécher le
boucher et elle doit être le boucher
donc le gars il est tant pis il va au
café et là ils demandent un whisky si je
vais me donner du courage
après je lui ai pété sa gueule il prend
une boisson petit whisky toi et au
moment où il repose irait une petite
goutte qui tombe tout doucement par
terre et là il ya une petite souris qui
sort et qui d'après lui ce qui est dit
au gars vient vraiment un autre ce qui
est à moi son deuxième but ce qui offre
une petite goutte la petite forêt et
apprécié whisky teacher's les petits
tailleurs des traverses suivi par la
petite souris non même état arrive elle
prend une petite pierre tuveri jette la
pierre leboucher où il fait c'est quoi
des sorts mais péter ta gueule un petite
souris à côté amène ton chat
[Rires]
oui j'ai bien ri